ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS. EIGHT
FACTOR FORTUS BRADFORD
CABALLERO CORTESE DALLY DODD TO
RAZA EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROVE HERTZBERG HUESO HURTADO.
JONES KAMLAGER WHERE'D LEYVA
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN
NIELSEN- SHOW VOGUE PAN
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
HOMBURG WHITE HOUSE SKI WIENER
WILK. MEMBERS OF A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR ATKINS
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL WE WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG BY SENATOR RUBIO.
GRACIOUS AND EVER LOVING GOD WE
COME BEFORE YOU WITH FRAGILE
LIVES WITH DREAMS HEARTS AND
BODIES TOO OFTEN SHATTERED.
WHAT CAN WE BELIEVE EXCEPT THAT
YOU WILL NOT DESPISE ARE
CARELESS AND BROKEN HEARTS WHAT
CAN WE BELIEVE EXCEPT THAT ONLY
WHAT IS FIRST BROKEN LIKE BREAD
CAN BE SHARED. GOD OF MERCY
HELP OUR UNBELIEF THAT WE MAY
HAVE THE COURAGE TO LOVE THE
ENEMIES WE HAVE THE INTEGRITY
TO MAKE. THAT WE MAY HAVE THE
AUDACITY TO GROW BEYOND OUR
SELF CENTERED PRAYERS AND
CAREFUL CREEDS TO BRING FORTH
THE JUST AND BELOVED SOCIETY
THAT IS OURS TO CREATE. THAT WE
MAY LEARN TO CARE FOR EACH
OTHER IN TRAGEDIES GREAT AND
SMALL. WE TRUST IN YOUR
UNFAILING HELP A MAN. NUMBER
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA AND TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS
ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. MEMBERS TODAY
WE HAVE A SENATOR LIMON AND
STERN PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME
SENATORS. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. UNDER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY WILL BE
WITHDRAWN FROM THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE AND
ORDERED TO THIRD READING.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF APRIL
TWELFTH THROUGH THE FIFTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION. OF
THE DAILY FILE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL MOVE TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. WE'RE
GONNA TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTY ONE SENATOR SKINNER.
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BURKE AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF SICK AFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR SKINNER
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU-
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. AB
AT IS THE. ACTION THAT WOULD
ALLOW OUR BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
RECIEVED PAYCHECK PROTECTION
LOANS AND WHOSE LOANS WERE
FORGIVEN IT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
HAVE TAX CONFORMITY- IN THEIR
CALIFORNIA TAXES THIS BILL WAS
HEARD IN OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE
ON FEBRUARY EIGHTEENTH HOWEVER
THE ACTION WAS DELAYED BECAUSE
THERE WAS A PROVISION IN THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT THAT
COULD HAVE PUT BY OUR
CALIFORNIA STATE A CALIFORNIA'S
FEDERAL FUNDS AT RISK. SO WE
FINALLY HAVE RECEIVED FEDERAL
GUIDANCE THAT ALLOWS US TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO ASSIST
START BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THE BILL HAS BEEN
RECENTLY AMENDED THE PRIMARY
DIFFERENCE IS THAT THE PRIOR
VERSION CAPPED. THE AMOUNTS
THAT BUSINESSES CAN DEDUCT FOR
THE EXPENSES. THAT THE-
EXPENSES USING FORGIVEN PPP
LOAN SIR WAS CAPPED AT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND WE
HAVE REMOVED THE CAP IN THIS
BILL ALLOWS BUSINESSES TO
DEDUCT ALL BUSINESS EXPENSES
PAID FOR WITH THE PPP LOAN THAT
WAS FORGIVEN EXCEPT FOR IF IT
WAS IF IT IS DEEMED TO BE AN
ILL ELIGIBLE ENTITY. ED IN
ELIGIBLE BUSINESSES OR THOSE
WHO DO NOT MEET THE REDUCTION
IN GROSS RECEIPTS OF 25% OR
MORE WHICH WAS A CONDITION OF
THE SECOND ROUND OF THE PPP
LOANS OTHERWISE THE BILL JUST
MAKES A FEW CONFORMING CHANGES
RELATED TO BOTH PPP LOANS AND
ECONOMIC- INJURY DISASTER
LOANS. AND THIS ACTION WILL
PROVIDE OUR CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN BENEFITS AND WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. WE NEED. TAKE A MINUTE.
WHAT.
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I JUST
WANTED TO SAY I'M IN SUPPORT I
CANNOT TELL YOU HOW MANY CALLS
WE'VE HAD OUR OFFICE FROM
PEOPLE TRYING TO PREPARE THEIR%
TAXES- OBVIOUSLY THEY HAVE
EXTENDED THE DEADLINE WHICH IS
VERY HELPFUL BUT MANY OF
BUSINESSES THAT ARE TRYING TO
PREPARE- THIS IS TIMELY AND AYE
ARJUN AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL AND
THIS GET THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
ABLE DO THEIR TAXES AND GET
BACK ON TRACK. THANK YOU.
CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I KNOW THERE WAS A
CONFUSION WITH THE- BOTH
ADMINISTRATIONS THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION HAD ALLOWED A
100% TAX DEDUCTION ON ANY OF
THESE LOANS AND THEN THE
ADMINISTRATION WE HAVE NOW HAD
TO- RESTRICTIONS ON GUN STATES
NOT BE ABLE TO REDUCE OUR TAXES
AND I'M SO GRATEFUL THAT THE IS
THAT THE SENATE PRO TEM THE
BUDGET CHAIR WERE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WORKS REALLY
HARD TO GET CLARITY OUT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION IN WASHINGTON DC
SO THAT WE CAN OFFER-
DEDUCTIONS TO THE BUSINESSES
THAT HAD APPLIED FOR THESE PPP
LOANS- LIKE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BEAVER. MY PHONE WAS RINGING
OFF THE HOOK BECAUSE PEOPLE
WERE YOU KNOW SAID I WOULDN'T
TAKE IT ALONE IF I KNEW I
WASN'T GONNA GET THESE
DEDUCTIONS AND THEY HAVE TO
TAKE THAT LOAN KEEP THEIR
EMPLOYEES EMPLOYED USE THAT
MONEY FOR RESOURCES TO MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE STILL HAD A
JOB AND WE'RE GOING TO BE
DISASTROUS ET DE PROCESS AND
THEN YOU HAVE TO PAY TAXES ON
THAT MANY AT THE END WAS- YOU
KNOW SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE WERE
VERY UPSET ABOUT SOMEONE I
THINK THE BUDGETARY FOR. MAKING
SURE THAT THIS GOT RESOLVED%
AND- IT JUST YEAH I. URGE A NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL. SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION- DEBATE.
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU I'M
PRESIDENT I ALSO- I'D URGE AND
I GO AND I ALSO REALLY WANT TO
THANK OUR BUDGET STAFF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO ADDRESS IS
REALLY A TEAM EFFORT- THESE
BUSINESSES ARE HURTING SO BADLY
AND- AND I JUST THINK THIS
MAKES ALL THE SENSE IN THE
WORLD PPP HAS ALWAYS BEEN
EXTREMELY BIPARTISAN PROGRAM
FEDERALLY IN HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- WE ALL WANT THESE
BUSINESSES TO SUCCEED THANK YOU.
SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU AYE
MADAM PRESIDENT CENTERS I TO
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
AGAIN REALLY APPRECIATE- THE
WORK- THE OF OUR- BUDGETS-
TEAMINDUS ARE BUDGET CHAIRS
WALLS ARE PRO TALLMAN OR
GOVERNOR MAKING THIS HAPPEN- IT
WAS A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER OF
THE AND ALSO CERTAINLY HEARING
FROM A LOT OF SMALL BUSINESSES
MANY BUSINESSES GOT TO KEEP THE
LAWN SO TRY TO KEEP PEOPLE ON
THE PAYROLL EVEN WHEN THEY
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH REVENUE TO
REALLY SUPPORT THAT AND- WAS WE
KNOW THE PDT LOANS REQUIRED YOU
TO SPEND 60% OF THE LOAN ON
PAYROLL ITSELF. SO P. AND
REALLY APPRECIATE WERE ABLE TO
DO THIS FOR THE BUSINESSES HERE
IN CALIFORNIA I REALLY
APPRECIATE. THE HARD WORK IT
TOOK TO MAKE IT HAPPEN THANK
YOU. SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU I
TO RISE IN US SUPPORT OF THIS
BUT JUST WANT TO PUT ON THE
RECORD IN HOPE GOING FORWARD
THAT DIED TWO OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE COMBINATION OF
THE CHAMBER THE BANKERS
ASSOCIATION COUCH TAX IN THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION WOULD BE
CONSIDERED AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD BECAUSE OTHERWISE IT
WOULD LOOK ODD TO SOME DEGREE
THAT THERE'S A FEW WINNER
THERE'S A LOT OF WINNERS BUT IF
YOU'RE A FEW LOSERS AND I THINK
WE'RE IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT.
THIS IS A REALLY FOR THE WHOLE
BUSINESS SECTOR THAT HAS
SUFFERED SO GREATLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC NOW THEY THEIR
EMPLOYEES IN PARTICULAR- SO
HOPEFULLY THEY'LL TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT AS IT MAKES ITS WAY
THROUGH THE PROCESS THANK YOU.
SENATOR HER. OF THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND I THINK TO BE
A PART TIME AND THE BUDGET
CHAIR FOR HITTING CLARITY AND-
MAKE IT WORK FOR OUR BUSINESSES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SENATE ROTH. THANK
YOU WRITTEN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TO TALK ABOUT ALL THE
TIME WERE BIPARTISAN SOLUTIONS
ARE THE BEST SOLUTIONS IN THE
LONGER LASTING AND HERE'S ONCE
AGAIN EXAMPLE WHERE WE'VE ALL
PULLED TOGETHER TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN TO HELP OUR SMALL
BUSINESS PEOPLE I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO BECAUSE
REALLY HIS LEGISLATION SB TWO
SIXTY FIVE WAS THE GENESIS OF
THIS PROGRAM. IT TOOK THE
GOVERNOR A LONG TIME TO GET TO
GET TO WHERE I THINK THIS BODY
WAS BUT HE ALMOST GOT THERE SO
EVEN THOUGH THIS IS A THIS IS A
GREAT EFFORT I THINK IT'S STILL
FALLS A LITTLE SHORT BUT
OBVIOUSLY WORTHY OF SUPPORT. J.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THIS CHAMBER
HAS CONTINUED TO LEAD IS NOT
AFRAID TO LEAD IN FACT RELISHES
THE CHALENGE AND THAT'S THE
GOVERNOR HAS MENTIONED THAT HE
WANTS TO OPEN UP SOCIETY ON THE
FIFTEENTH OF JUNE I REALLY
BELIEVE IT'S NOW TIME FOR US TO
TAKE A LOOK AT TERMINATING THIS
EMERGENCY ACT I DON'T THINK WE
NEEDED ANYMORE I THINK EVERY
CALIFORNIA BENEFITS FROM HAVING
A COMPLETE GOVERNMENT WHERE YOU
HAVE THE PROPER CHECKS AND
BALANCES- THAT IS LAID OUT IN
THE CONSTITUTION. SO I HOPE-
THE LEADERSHIP IN THIS HOUSE
WILL- CONTEMPLATE MOVING S. C.
R. FIVE FROM THE MY GOOD MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM LAKE ELSINORE
SO WE CAN AGAIN BE A CO EQUAL
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT AND WITH
THAT I REGION. AYE VOTE FOR
THIS MEASURE. SENATOR TO LET.
THANK YOU MANAGER RIGHT TO RISE
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL IT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE BUSINESS OWNER
SMALL BUSINESSES EVERY SINGLE
DAY WE HEAR THE STORIES OF MOM
AND POP NEEDING HELP THIS IS
OUR WAY OF COMING TOGETHER IS A
SENATE COMING TOGETHER AS A
CITY CALIFORNIA SAY WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE AND
NOW WE'RE TAKING THE BIG STEP
FORWARD THEY SEE THAT WE CAN
COME TOGETHER AS WE SURE WE
HEARD THE TERM. WE CAN DO THIS
TOGETHER WELL NOW WE'RE GOING
TO DO THIS TOGETHER AND I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
ALL BE VERY PROUD OF AND I URGE
THE AYE VOTE THANK YOU. CENTER
EGGMAN. IN SUPPORT OF. SENATE
MA'AM IF YOU COULD JUST WAIT A
MINUTE WE'LL GET YOUR MIKE ON.
IF I COULD JUST RISE. IN
SUPPORT OF AB. SB EIGHTY AS
WELL. AND I KNOW THIS IS A WORK
OF BOTH HOUSES AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AND COMING
TOGETHER TO GET THIS DONE FOR
OUR SMALL BUSINESS BUT I'M NOT
ONLY THAT. ARE NONPROFIT TO
HAVE BEEN ON THE FRONT LINE IS
ESSENTIAL WORKERS OUT THERE
DOING THIS WORK. I WHO HAVE
ALSO BEEN GREATLY DAMAGED. BY
THIS PANDEMIC AS WE COME OUT
THE OTHER SIDE. IT'S A BUT MOST
IMPORTANT THAT WE PROVIDE ALL
THE RESOURCES AND SUPPORT WE
CAN. TO BOTH OUR BUSINESSES
LARGE AND SMALL AS WELL AS OUR
NONPROFIT TO ARE ALSO OUT THERE
STRUGGLING TO CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES THAT ARE SO
IMPORTANT AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU
MADAM. I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHTY AND YOU KNOW I.
DON'T WANT TO BELABOR THE POINT
BUT WE'VE ALL SEEN SO MANY OF
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES STRUGGLING
TO STAY AFLOAT. CONSTANTLY
REACHING OUT TO MY OFFICE IS
I'M SURE MY COLLEAGUES AS WELL
AND I THINK IT'S- A GREAT
SOLUTION IT'S GREAT TO SEE. ALL
OF US COME TOGETHER FOR THIS.
IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT WILL
REALLY WILL HELP. IN IN OUR
EFFORTS THE PANDEMIC HAS BEEN
DEVASTATING. TO OUR COMMUNITY
SAID. THAT IF WE CAN DO IS
STEP. UP AND UP FOR THESE
POLICIES THAT WILL HELP IN THIS
AND THOSE EFFORTS. BUT THAT I
ALSO ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU.
CENTER HERTZBERG. THANK VERY
MUCH WHEN PRESIDENTS TO RISE IN
SUPPORT AND GIVE MY-
CONGRATULATIONS TO THE BUDGET
CHAIR BUDGET TEAM IN BOTH HER
OFFICE AND IN THE PRO TEM'S
OFFICE AS WELL AS THE PROTON
THIS IS REALLY AN ELEGANT
SOLUTION TO- QUITE DIFFICULT
CHALLENGES COSTS A LOT OF MONEY
AND THANK GOD WE HAVE A LOT OF
MONEY NOW IN CALIFORNIA FROM
THE FEDS AND ALSO FROM THE-
KANEMI THAT IS SURPRISINGLY
OCCURRED HERE SO I'M JUST I
THINK IT'S A QUITE PRACTICAL
SOLUTION BY LOOKING AT THE
PERCENTAGE RATHER THAN LOOKING
AT CATEGORIES THAT WE HAD
DISCUSSED BEFORE. VERY HAPPY TO
SEE IT AND- ASK YOUR STRONG
SUPPORTERS MEASURE. SENATOR
AKOWSKI. THANK YOU MA'AM-
PERSON I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR- ALONG THIS LINE
BECAUSE IN WHEN WE FIRST DID
PPV OR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THAT THE PPP ONE IT WAS TO HELP
KEEP BUSINESSES OPEN GIVE MONEY
TO HARPER PAY FOR THE EMPLOYEES
PREVENT THE ECONOMY FROM
CRASHING YEAH THE DATA NOW WHEN
THEY WHEN WE HEARD AB EIGHTY
EIGHT WAS A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS YOU KNOW
EXCLUSION IF YOU MADE MORE THAN
HAVE YOU COULD DEDUCT UP TO
HUNDRED FIFTY NOT GOING WITH
THE PERCENTAGE OF 25% UNDER PPP
TWO- ARE WE ARE AT RISK OF
HAVING MANY SMALL BUSINESSES.
THAT HAVE A 19% LOSS OR AN 18%
LOSS THAT THE THAT THAT
BORROWED MONEY UNDER PPP ONE
WILL HAVE TO I DO HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT INCOME AND IS.
I GUESS FOR. WHAT DOES IT
MINISTRY SAVE THAT. HE SAID
THAT CENTER SKINNER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ADDRESS THAT IN YOUR
CLOSING OR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ANSWER THAT RIGHT NOW.
WHICHEVER YOUR PREFERENCES
MADAM PRESIDENT. IF YOU COULD
ANSWER IT RIGHT NOW IT LOOKS
LIKE CENTER IT MIGHT COST IS
NOT FINISHED SO LET'S OKAY NICE
RIGHT NOW THEN WE CAN- SO THE
SPECIFIC THAT- THE SENATOR FROM
FOR YOUR OWN IS REFERRING TO IS
THAT. THE WHAT MAKES A BUSINESS
WHO MAY HAVE RECEIVED A LOAN IN
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS DEDUCTION IS
THE SAME CRITERIA THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ITSELF USED
FOR THE USE RING OF LOANS IN
THE SECOND ROUND WHICH IS THAT.
THE BUSINESS WOULD HAVE HAD TO
HAVE A LOT SHOWN A LOSS IN
GROSS RECEIPTS OF 20% 5% OR
HIGHER IN TWENTY TWENTY THAT'S
COMPARED TO THE SAME TIME
PERIOD IN TWENTY NINETEEN. SO
IT DOES NOT MEAN THAT THE
BUSINESS WOULD HAVE NECESSARILY
HAD TO SHOW A- THE- REDUCTION
IN GROSS RECEIPTS OF 25% OVER
THE ENTIRE YEAR BUT RATHER FOR
THE PERIOD. FOR WHICH THEY ARE
CLAIMING SO- THERE ARE
ESTIMATIONS ARE IT IT WELL IT
DOES EXCLUDE SOME BUSINESSES
IT'S A VERY SMALL NUMBER. THANK
YOU SO MUCH IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER BURGESS. THANK YOU FOR
THE PRESIDENT AND I DO WANT TO
EXTEND MY- D. WAS APPRECIATION
OF MY COLLEAGUES- WHO WERE
HELPFUL IN ALLOWING ME TO BE
HERE TODAY I THINK I. THINK I
RAN A MILE LIKE SIX AFTER SEVEN
MINUTES. THE VIRGINIA FROM A
LOT OF BREATH. THIS IS WANTED
TO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR-
LEGISLATIVE LEADERS COURSE THE
BUDGET YEAR ON. PHOTO MACINNES
AND ALL THOSE WHO SPEND TIME
WORKING ON THIS BILL. SOME OF
YOU MAY REMEMBER THAT. MY
COLLEAGUE AND I FROM SALINAS
INTRODUCED A BILL A LONG TIME
AGO THE SEVENTY FOUR SB SEVENTY
FOR THE KEEP CALIFORNIA WORKING
AT. IT WAS DURING THAT THE
CRAFTING OF THE BILL. THAT THE
ISSUE OF WHAT WOULD BE A
TAXABLE EVENT. WAS BROUGHT UP.
AND UPON FURTHER INQUIRY WE
REALIZE THAT. INDEED THERE WERE
COMPONENTS OF FEDERAL FUNDING
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE
ELIGIBLE FOR TAXABLE BE
CONSIDERED TAXABLE EVENT. AND I
THINK. BY INTRODUCING SB TWO
SIX FIVE IN JANUARY. IN
JANUARY- WE WERE ABLE TO EARN A
LOT OF SUPPORT BECAUSE I THINK
A LOT OF FOLKS JUST DIDN'T FEEL
THAT WOULD BE. OTHERWISE FAIR.
FOR EMERGENCY RELIEF FUNDING
FROM THE FEDS. THE TAX AT THE
STATE LEVEL. AND I THINK
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM INCLUDING
THE LEADERSHIP AGREED WITH THAT
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR AND
OTHER FLKS THAT WE HAD THE KEY
PROVISIONS OF TWO SIX FIVE
CORPORATE INTO AB AT AND FOR
THAT I'M- ABSOLUTELY GRATEFUL
FOR. AND WE HAVE AN ONLINE
PETITION IN THOUSANDS OF FOLKS
SUPPORT. ALL THE SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND ALL THE FOLKS
WITHIN OUR DISTRICTS SO FOLKS
WITHOUT FURTHER DELAY I AM
ACTUALLY PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB
EIGHTY AS EMERGENCY EARLY
ACTION ITEM IN THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR EVERYONE WHO
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS. PROCESS
THANK YOU. SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CENTER
SKINNER YOU MAY CONCLUDE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- JUST IS- TERMS
OF SCALE IN CALIFORNIA THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDED
NINETY SEVEN BILLION IN P. P.
P. AND THE YEAH IDEA OR
ECONOMIC INJURY DISASTER LOANS
AND ABOUT IT WAS ABOUT A
MILLION LOANS. AND THE AVERAGE
WAS ABOUT. NINETY SIX THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
WAS THE AVERAGE LOAN. SO AS I
MENTIONED THIS WOULD ALLOW FOR
THE TAX CONFORMITY WITH A FEW
EXCEPTIONS THAT I DESCRIBED AND
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
WITHOUT AND THE FLOOR WITHOUT I
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOOKED. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
AYE BATES HI BACKER HI BORJAS.
HI BRADFORD HI CABRERA HI
TESTING I DALLY. HI DODD I TO
RAZA HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HI HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO FIVE FURTADO FIVE
JONES. HI KAMLAGER HI LAYERED
FIVE LEYVA HI MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ AYE MIN. HI NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN. PHOTOBOOK HI PAN HI
PORTANTINO HI ROTH AYE RUBIO HI
SKINNER. HI I'M BURKE I LIKE
CASKEY HI WIENER. I WILK HI
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE ON TO SECOND READING
FILE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY
SIX OF AMENDMENTS FOR WITH
AMENDMENTS SUPPORT TWENTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS SIX SIXTY TWO
WITH AMENDMENTS AT SIX OH THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS SEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS SIX FORTY
NINE WITH AMENDMENTS THE SECOND
READING FILE IS DEEMED READ SO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT. I ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN SENATOR LAYERED.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS FILE ITEM FOURTEEN IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF ANTONIO
BENJAMIN FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES FINANCING AUTHORITY
HE IS A PARTNER AT PA
CONSULTING HE IS THE CO FOUNDER
AND CHIEF TECHNOLOGY OFFER
OFFICER EMERITUS OF TOKEN
pTHE RULES COMMITTEE ON APRIL
SEVENTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FAST
FOR NINE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION ENTERED OR DEBATE ON
THIS APPOINTMENT. SEEING NONE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
I BAKER. I PORCHES I BRADFORD
HI COME BY ADAM HI CORTESE. HI
DALLY HI DODD HI THE RAZA. I
EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. FIVE HERTZBERG HI
WITH SO. HI HURTADO HI JONES
FIVE KAMLAGER. I LAYERED. HI
LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ
HI MEN HI NEWMAN I NIELSEN. A
SHOW OF BOTH. I CAN HI
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER HI I'M BURKE HI WE
CASTING I WIENER HI WILK. HI IS
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO
DEPARTMENT IS CONFIRMED. MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN
CENTER LAYERED THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM FIFTEEN IS
ALSO CONSERVATION A
CONFIRMATION OF AN APPOINTMENT
TO THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
FACILITIES FINANCING AUTHORITY
DOES FRANCISCO SILVA MR SILVA
IS GENERAL COUNSEL AND SENIOR
VICE PRESIDENT FOR LEGAL
AFFAIRS HEALTH POLICY AND
ECONOMICS SERVICES AT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
HE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON APRIL SEVENTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
AYE BATES BAKER HI PORGES.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI
CORTESE HI DALLY. DODD HI
TORONTO. I EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER
HI GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES. KAMLAGER I
LAYERED I LEYVA HI MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ NO MAN HI NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN. OTOBO PAN HI
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH HI RUBIO.
HI SKINNER. HI NUMBER I BY
KELSEY HI WIENER HI WILK NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES PORGES. DALLY GROVE NO
JONES. NIELSEN BUT CHAU VOGUE.
PRICE TWENTY NINE KNOWS THREE
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
SENATE THIRD READING WHEN IT
START WITH ITEM FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY THREE SENATOR
SKINNER ARE YOU PREPARED SHE IS
PLEASE. PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION SIX BY SENATOR
SKINNER RELATIVE TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CENTERS
SKINNER THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M PLEASED
TO PRESENT S. C. R. SIX WHICH
COMMEMORATES THE FORTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT'S RULING IN ROE
VERSUS RAID. ROVERS'S WAIT A
RULING THAT WAS ISSUED ON
JANUARY TWENTY SECOND. NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE. IT WAS A
LANDMARK RULING AND WHAT IT CAN
CHANGE WHAT'S THE JUSTICES
ASSERTION THAT THE FOURTEENTH
AMENDMENT PROVIDES AND THE
AMENDMENTS RIGHT TO PRIVACY
THAT THAT RIGHT TO PRIVACY.
PROTECTS A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE WHETHER OR NOT TO HAVE
AN ABORTION. THE SUPREME COURT
IN THAT RULING CLASSIFIED THE
RIGHT TO CHOOSE THAT'S
FUNDAMENTAL WHICH REQUIRED
LOWER COURTS TO EVALUATE
CHALLENGED ABORTION LAWS UNDER
THE STRICT SCRUTINY STANDARD
WHICH IS THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
JUDICIAL REVIEW IN THE UNITED
STATES. KNOW THAT LANGUAGE WAS
WEAKENED SLIGHTLY IN THE
NINETIES WHICH OPENED THE DOOR
TO THE LEGISLATIVE ATTACKS THAT
WE NOW SEE BY MANY STATES WERE
TRYING TO A ROAD THAT CHOICE.
BUT FUNDAMENTALLY BOTH THE
RULING AND A WOMAN'S RIGHT OVER
HER REPRODUCTIVE CHOICES REMAIN.
THE LAW OF THE LAND. BEFORE
THAT RULING IN ROE VERSUS WADE
ABOUT A MILLION WOMEN A YEAR IN
THE UNITED STATES RESORTED TO
ILLEGAL ABORTION ED WHICH LED
THEN TO OVER FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND ANNUAL DEATHS. NO ONE
FORTUNATELY AS I REFERENCED DUE
TO A WEAKENING OF THE RULING IN
THE NINETIES. THERE HAVE BEEN
MANY STATE ACTIONS TO TRY TO
WEAKEN. BROUGH VERSUS WADE AND
IN THE LAST EIGHT YEARS ALONE
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE
NEW TATE LEVEL RESTRICTIONS
HAVE BEEN ENACTED NOT ALL HAVE
BEEN APPEALED BUT THAT SO MANY
HAVE BEEN PASSED BY DIFFERENT
LEGISLATURES. CLINIC VIOLENCE
AND THREATS WHEN PROVIDERS ARE
ON THE RISE. AARON IT IS MORE
AND MORE DIFFICULT FOR WOMEN TO
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT DEPENDING
ON WHERE THEY LIVE BECAUSE OF
HAVING NO CLINIC ANYWHERE NEAR
THEM. AS A REFLECT ON THIS
ANNIVERSARY I THINK ABOUT THE
CURRENT SUPREME COURT AND
WHETHER THAT CURRENT MAJORITY
WILL RESPECT THE WILL OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THE ONE I
REFERENCE THE WILL I MEAN. THAT
POLLS AS RECENT AS AUGUST
TWENTY NINETEEN SHOW THAT SEVEN
IN TEN AMERICANS DO NOT WANT
ROE VERSUS WADE OVERTURNED. AND
IN FACT THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS 59% HAVE INDICATED A
GREATER CONCERN IS WITH STATES
THAT ARE MAKING IT TOO
DIFFICULT FOR WOMEN TO EXERCISE
THEIR REPRODUCTIVE CHOICES.
FORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA HAS A
LONG HISTORY OF SUPPORTING A
WOMAN'S PERSONAL DECISIONS
REGARDING HER REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH INCLUDING ABORTION. AND
WE HAVE EXPANDED ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE BY
MANDATING INSURANCE COVERAGE.
FOR MANDATING INSURANCE
COVERAGE AND ALSO EXPANDING THE
LOW INCOME ACCESS FOR ABORTION
SERVICES WE'VE ALSO EXPANDED
ACCESS TO. MEDICATION ABORTION
AT ALL UNIVERSITY HEALTH
CENTERS. S. R. SIX REMINDS US
THAT THE WORK OF ENSURING A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE IS NOT
DONE. EVERY WOMAN DESERVES TO
MAKE THIS DECISION FOR HERSELF
EVERY WOMAN DESERVES FINANCIAL
AND MEDICAL SUPPORT. AND I
THINK WE ALL UNDERSTAND THAT
GENDER EQUITY WILL REMAIN
ELUSIVE UNTIL WOMEN HAVE FULL
AGENCY TO DETERMINE THEIR
REPRODUCTIVE DECISIONS AND FULL
ABILITY TO ACCESS AND ACT ON
THOSE DECISIONS. AND WITHOUT I
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. SENATOR
DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I WATCH THIS
RESOLUTION COMMON GOAL FOR THE
PAST EIGHT YEARS AND I HAVE SAT
SILENTLY. MY SILENCE HAS BECOME
THE LOUDEST VOICE IN MY HEAD.
THIS IS DEDICATED TO MY
DAUGHTER ROSLYN ROSLYN YOUR
SMILE BRIGHTENS MY DAY. YOUR
LOVE FOR LIFE IS CONTAGIOUS
YOUR BRAVE AND ELEVEN YEARS OLD
YOU NEVER CEASE TO AMAZE ME.
YOU ARE BEAUTIFUL AS YOUR DADDY
I CAN'T WISH BUT THE YEARS
WOULD SLOW DOWN. YOU ARE
GROWING UP TOO QUICKLY. YOU ARE
THE YOUNGEST ANNUAL FOREVER BE
MY BABY GIRL. WHEN WATSON WAS
BE INFORMED BY OUR CREATOR GOD
IN HER MOTHER'S WOMB WE WERE
TOLD THERE WAS NO HEARTBEAT AND
THERE WASN'T A BABY IT WAS
SIMPLY A POSITIVE A FALSE
POSITIVE. BUT THE SONOGRAM
SHOWED HER TINY FRAME. WE WERE
PAINFULLY TOLD TO GET ARE NOT
WE WERE PAINFULLY TOLD NOT TO
GET OUR HOPES UP AND THE DNC
WAS THE BEST CHOICE. THIS NEVER
BECAME OUR TRUTH WE HELD ON
YOUR HOPE AND TOLD OURSELVES TO
WAIT TWO WEEKS. WHAT IF OUR
BABY WAS THERE WHAT IF IT
WASN'T A FALSE POSITIVE WHAT IF.
TWO WEEKS LATER MY WIFE AND I
WENT TO HER HER DOCTOR'S
APPOINTMENT AND FOR THE FIRST
TIME WE HEARD ROZ'S HEARTBEAT.
WE CRIED OUR DOCTOR CRIED WITH
THIS IT WAS A BEAUTIFUL MOMENT
I STAND HERE TODAY AS A VOICE.
A VOICE FOR THOSE WHO HAVEN'T
LOST THEIR VOICE. A VOICE FOR
THOSE WHO WILL NEVER GIVEN A
CHANCE TO BE LOVED BY THEIR
FATHER AND MOTHER. THE ONES WHO
WILL NEVER KNOW WHAT THE FIRST
DAY OF KINDERGARTEN IS LIKE. OR
LEARN TO RIDE A BIKE. OR FOR
THE ONE WHO WILL NEVER WALK
DOWN THE AISLE WEDDING I'LL
TODAY I STAND AS A VOICE FOR
THE VOICELESS. HERE ARE A FEW
STATISTICS ABORTION IS THE
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH
WORLDWIDE KILLING MORE THAN
FORTY TWO POINT SIX MILLION
BABIES IN JUST TWENTY TWENTY
ALONE HIGHER THAN AIDS CANCER
MALARIA AND OTHERS COMBINED
ACCORDING TO THE REPORT
RELEASED BY WORLD METERS BASED
ON THE WORLD HORSE HEALTH
ORGANIZATION SUCH AS X. AS OF
DECEMBER. THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THERE HAVE BEEN TWELVE POINT
FIVE MILLION ABORTIONS
WORLDWIDE. THAT IS AN AVERAGE
OF THREE MILLION ABORTIONS A
MONTH AND APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
TWO THOUSAND A DAY. SOURCE
WORLD- METERS WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION IN THE U. S. THERE
ARE OVER THREE THOUSAND
ABORTIONS PER DAY. 22% OF ALL
PREGNANCIES IN THE U. S.
EXCLUDING MISCARRIAGES IN AN
ABORTION. CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF
THE TOP TEN STATES FOR ABORTION
RATES IN THE US. WE MUST
CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR BETTER
SOLUTIONS. WE CAN DO BETTER WE
MUST. WE HAVE A BUDGET SURPLUS.
WE HAVE FUNDING TO PROVIDE
GREATER EDUCATION AND EDUCATION
AND POWERS. FOR THOSE REASONS
AND MANY MORE MEMBERS I WILL
NOT BE SUPPORTING THIS
RESOLUTION TODAY THANK YOU.
SENATOR GONZALEZ. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR-
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD-
THERE ARE STILL MANY BARRIERS
TO ACCESSING ABORTION IN
CALIFORNIA EVEN THOUGH WE ARE
CONSIDERED A LEADING STATE IN
THE FIGHT FOR A PRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM AND ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE WE
STILL SO MANY BARRIERS IN ORDER
TO CONTINUE TO LEAD THE WAY
INTO TRULY UPHOLD THE VALUES
THESE VALUES WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT ABORTION AND REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ARE
ACCESSIBLE AND EQUITABLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS NOT. ONLY ONLY
THOSE WHO CAN AFFORD IT. THE
ALL TOO SIMILAR FAMILIAR
STATISTICS AND STORIES. PORTION
ACCESS THIS IS THE GRIM REALITY
OF INJUSTICE WHEN SYSTEMIC
INEQUITY IS ALLOWED TO
CONTINUE. IT IS PEOPLE OF COLOR
TRANS NON BINARY PEOPLE PEOPLE
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES PEOPLE OF.
ALL ETHNIC BACKGROUNDS AND
SOCIOECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS AS
WELL THAT FACE THE WORST AND
ARE SPECIALLY HARMED AS IT
PERTAINS TO REPRODUCTIVE.
HEALTH CARE ACCESS THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE TOO. GREAT AND
WHEN CABS CALIFORNIANS SHOULD
UPHOLD THIS RIGHT. AND FOR THAT
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
SENATOR SKINNER AND IS A PROUD
MEMBER OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS AND I
HOPE MY COLLEAGUES WILL DO TO.
SKINNER GROVE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I WOULD AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER THAT AND
FOR YEARS WE'VE SAT SILENT ON
THIS FLOOR AND NOT DEFENDED-
DEARBORN WE'VE JUST VOTED NO ON
THESE PARTICULAR PIECES OF
LEGISLATION- WHEN ROE VERSUS
WADE PAST THERE WASN'T THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE HAD- THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE TO US TODAY WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT WE HAVE TODAY- I WAS
BLESSED THIS PAST YEAR TO HAVE
TWO GRAND BABIES BORN ON THE
SAME DAY. EVERY SECOND AND WE
GOT TO GO WATCH THEIR
ULTRASOUNDS WHERE THEY HAVE THE
NEW THREE D. AND FIVE D.
VERSIONS AND THEY HAVE A
PERSONALITY OF THEIR OWN EVEN
AT TWENTY WEEKS TWENTY FIVE
WEEKS THIRTY TWO WEEKS AND THEY
SET THEIR THUMBS- WE GET TELL
TYLER WAS GONNA HAVE LITTLE
TINY LIVES LIKE YOUR DAD AND WE
CAN HELP RALLY WAS GOING TO
HAVE REALLY NICE BIG LIPS LIKE
HER MOM HIS MOM. AND WE COULD
TELL THAT PROBABLY WAS GOING TO
BE LONGER AND PROBABLY WAY MORE
THAN TYLER- BUT YOU KNOW
COUSINS NONETHELESS IN WE COULD
SEE THAT EACH ONE OF THEM HAVE
THEIR OWN PERSONALITY EVEN
INSIDE THEIR MOTHER'S WOMBS-
THE REPORT IN FEBRUARY IT WAS
THE RIGHT TO LIFE MEANT AND I
POSTED A PICTURE BECAUSE BIRD
ALLOWED IN THE HOSPITAL BECAUSE
OF THE RESPONSE TO KOBE DIDN'T
ALLOW PARENTS IN THERE. BUT MY
SON IN LAW TOOK A PICTURE OF MY
GRANDSON. TWO SECONDS MAYBE
AFTER HE CAME OUT OF THE WHEN
HE SAW THE UMBILICAL CORD
ATTACHED. IT CAME OUT HIS
HANDS. AND THEN HE WAS CRYING
OF COURSE AND THEN. I CAN'T
EVEN IMAGINE THAT. MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE THINK THAT. TEN
SECONDS BEFORE THAT PHOTO. THAT
THAT IS NOT A LIFE. TEN SECONDS
BEFORE THAT PHOTO WAS TAKEN MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE SAY THAT THAT IS NOT
A LIFE AND THE WOMAN HAS A
RIGHT TO CHOOSE TO TERMINATE.
THAT BABY. M. THINGS NEED TO
CHANGE THINGS DEFINITELY NEED
TO CHANGE THERE'S NEW
TECHNOLOGY OUT THERE THAT SHOWS
THAT THESE BABIES IN THE WOMB
HAVE PAIN THAT THESE BABIES IN
THE WOMB FEEL PAIN THIRTY- THAT
THEY LEARN AND THEY DEVELOP
THEIR OWN PERSONALITIES IT WAS
JUST AMAZING TO ME LIKE I. WHEN
THE OTHER KIDS HAVE THEIR
BABYSITTING HAVE THIS
TECHNOLOGY OUT THERE AND SO WAS
THIS YEAR THIS PAST YEAR HAS
BEEN JUST A LEARNING
EXPERIENCE- I WAS ALWAYS IN PRO
LIFE BUT- THIS PARTICULAR
EXPERIENCE THIS LAST YEAR WHEN
I WAS ABLE TO SEE THE SONOGRAMS
OF THE FIVE D. PORTION. IT'S
LIKE LOOKING AT A REAL
PHOTOGRAPHS. OF THE BABY IN THE
WOMB- I WOULD. ASK MY
COLLEAGUES TO- TAKE A DEEP
BREATH CAN SUPPORT THOSE THOSE
YOUNG GIRLS THAT WILL NEVER BE
BORN THOSE YOUNG BOYS THAT MAY
HAVE A PROMISING FUTURE- THAT
WILL HAVE A PROMISING FUTURE IF
THEY WERE ABLE TO BE BORN. I
WOULD LIKE YOU TO THINK ABOUT
THE FOUNDING OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND HOW MARGARET
SANGER AND HOW IT ACTUALLY
STARTED AND WHERE THOSE
SPECIFIC CLINICS ARE ACTUALLY
LOCATED AND HOW THAT IS TRULY A
RACIAL ISSUE. AND I WOULD ASK
YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU. SENATOR
MELENDEZ. GOOD TO GO THERE WE
GO THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE
SPOKEN IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
RESOLUTION PARTICULARLY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BEAVER I THOUGHT
THOSE WERE VERY POIGNANT
REMARKS TO MAKE. TO HIS
DAUGHTER. OKAY SORRY YOU'RE
LOOKING AT ME AS THOUGH THERE'S
A PROBLEM MY APOLOGIES- MY OWN
DAUGHTER HINO SHE'S EIGHTEEN
NOW AND SHE'S GOING TO BE GOING
OFF TO COLLEGE AND I HOPE THAT-
SHOULD SHE EVER FIND HERSELF IN
A POSITION WHERE SHE'S.
PREGNANT AND WASN'T PLANNING ON
BEING PREGNANT THAT SHE FALL
BACK ON. WHAT SHE WAS TAUGHT IN
THE HOME WHICH SHE WAS TAUGHT
IN HER CHURCH THAT EVERY- WITH
THE LIFE IN THE WOMB GOD HAS
CREATED AND TO TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION I DON'T. I FEEL
AS THOUGH AFTER HAVING BEEN IN
THE LEGISLATURE NOW FOR ALMOST
TEN YEARS THAT. IS IF THERE IS
AN EFFORT FOR CALIFORNIA TO BE
NUMBER ONE IN. IN PROVIDING THE
MOST NUMBER OF ABORTIONS IN THE
COUNTRY I DON'T THINK THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING WE SHOULD BE
STRIVING TOWARD I DON'T THINK
PUSHING POLICIES. THAT TAKE THE
LIFE OF AN IS AN INNOCENT CHILD
THOSE AREN'T VALUES. THOSE ARE
NOT VALUES. WE TALK ALL THE
TIME IN THESE CHAMBERS ABOUT.
THE VALUE OF A LIFE THE
SANCTITY OF THE LIFE. AND I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY DOT
MINDSET DOESN'T APPLY WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AN UNBORN
CHILD. ABORTION. PUSHING
POLICIES THAT MAKE IT EASIER TO
GET AN ABORTION TO MAKE IT
CHEAPER TO GET AN ABORTION TO
MAKE THEM MORE ABUNDANT THOSE
ARE NOT VALUES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR DON'T VOTE THANK YOU.
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE SENATE-
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU ROAD
SHOWS TO PRESENT I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORTER OF AS OUR SIX
YEAR PEOPLE CAN HAVE WHATEVER
PERSONAL VIEWS- THEY WANT TO
HAVE ABOUT ABORTION AND WHAT
MAKES SENSE OF WHAT A WOMAN
BELIEVES MAKE SENSE FOR HER AND
HER LIFE AND- THOSE ARE ALL
OPINIONS AT EACH PERSON AS AN
INDIVIDUAL HIGHS- BUT THE ISSUE
HERE. IS WHETHER WOMEN HAVE THE
AGENCY AND THE INDEPENDENCE AS
HUMAN BEINGS TO MAKE CHOICES
ABOUT THEIR OWN BODIES AND
ABOUT THEIR OWN LIVES. AND
FRANKLY IT'S NONE OF MY
BUSINESS. WHETHER WOMAN DECIDES
SHE WHETHER SHE WANTS TO GET
PREGNANT WHETHER SHE WANTS TO
CARRY TO TERM THAT IS HER
CHOICE AND HER CHOICE. ALONE
AND WE HAVE MOVED PAST THE
POINT IN TIME NOT EVERYWHERE IN
THE WORLD BUT WE SAY WE MOVED
PAST IN THIS COUNTRY. THE POINT
IN TIME WHERE WOMEN WERE VIEWED
AS PROPERTY OF THEIR HUSBANDS
OR THEY WERE SUBSERVIENT IN
SOCIETY AND THEY JUST HAD TO DO
WHAT THEY WERE TOLD- THAT'S NO
LONGER. THE CASE IN THIS
COUNTRY AND I HOPE ONE DAY
AROUND THE WORLD- AND IF A
WOMAN CAN MAKE REPRODUCTIVE
CHOICES FOR HERSELF AND CONTROL
HER OWN BODY AND CONTROL THE
TIMING OF WHETHER AND WHEN- SHE
HAS A CHILD. THEN THERE IS NO
WAY THAT WE CAN HAVE THAT FULL
INDEPENDENCE AGENCY AND
EQUALITY. SO I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TO RISE
IN SUPPORT AND I'M KIND OF
MIXED HERE BECAUSE PERSONALLY.
I BELIEVE IN LIFE IN PRO LIFE.
BUT I. WHOLEHEARTEDLY INSTEAD
FAST BELIEVE IN A WOMAN'S RIGHT
TO CHOOSE A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO DO
WITH HER BODY AS SHE SEES FIT.
THEY MANY TIMES WHEN
INDIVIDUALS CHOOSE TO HAVE AN
ABORTION IT'S NOT JUST SIMPLY
THE TERMINATOR PRESENT A
PREGNANCY IT MIGHT BE BECAUSE
OF HEALTH COMPLICATIONS BOTH
FOR THE WOMAN AND THE FOETUS-
BUT THERE ARE TIMES WHEN IT'S
ONE OF. MATURITY. THEIR ABILITY
TO RAISE A CHILD THE FINANCIAL
WORLD WERE ABOUT TO PROVIDE FOR
THAT CHILD AND I GUESS MY REAL
ROB HERE IS THAT. THOSE WHO ARE
STILL PRO LIFE IN THE WOMB.%
WELL THE FIRST ADVOCATE FOR
DEATH OF THAT SAME INDIVIDUAL
ONCE THEY BECOME A TEAM AND
THEY CROSS THE LINE. SO YOU
CAN'T BE PRO LIFE IN THE WOMB
N. M. PRO DEATH ONCE THEY
BECOME AN ADULT SO ON THAT
REASON AND THOSE REASONS HI
SCOTT FOR AYE VOTE. SENATOR
KAMLAGER. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SR SIX- I
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE FOCUS THIS DISCUSSION
ON HEALTH EQUITY AND HEALTH
ACCESS. ACHIEVING HEALTH EQUITY
REQUIRES FINDING THE SYSTEMIC
RACISM THAT CREATES BARRIERS TO
ALL KINDS OF SEXUAL AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE. WE
HAVE SEEN FROM THIS PAST YEAR
THAT THE PANDEMIC HAS LAID BARE
SO MANY RACIAL DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH CARE. BUT WE CAN ALSO
SEE WHO IS MOST AFFECTED. BY
INCREASED ABORTION RESTRICTIONS
AND IN SKYROCKETING SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASE GREAT. WE
ARE CONTINUING TO FACE
RELENTLESS ATTACKS ON OUR
ABILITY TO KEEP PROVIDING
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE YES INCLUDING ABORTION.
AND THOSE ATTACKS EQUATE THE
SILENCING OF WOMEN. WOMEN ARE
NOT A MONOLITHIC GROUP. WOMEN
SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO WITH THEIR
BODIES AND HOW THEY WANT TO
LIVE. N. AS WE FIGHT SO OFTEN
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ALL HAVE A
RIGHT. WHY DOES IT SEEM TO BE
OKAY. TO DENY THE RIGHTS OF
WOMEN TO MAKE CHOICES ABOUT HOW
WE WANT TO LIVE. THERE WAS A
REALLY GREAT OP ED. IN LAST
WEEK'S NEW YORK TIMES WRITTEN
BY ALEXIS MCGILL JOHNSON THE
CURRENT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD- ACTUALLY
QUITE ELOQUENTLY TALKS ABOUT.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD'S FOUNDING
AND ITS FOUNDER. AND NO LONGER
EXCUSES. THE VALUES AND
BEHAVIOR OF THAT PARTICULAR
PERSON. EUGENICS WRONG
AFFILIATING WITH THE KLU KLUX
KLAN WRONG. CENTRALIZING BLACK
AND BROWN IN IMMIGRANT WOMEN
WRONG. BUT FOCUSING ON BODILY
AUTONOMY AND SELF DETERMINATION
FOR WOMEN IS SOMETHING QUITE
FRANKLY WE ALL SHOULD BE
SUPPORTING. FINN ABORTIONS ARE
NOT ONE IN THE SAME. MANY FOLKS
HAVE THEM BECAUSE WHAT'S
GROWING INSIDE OF THEM STOPS
GROWING. IT STOPS GROWING. AND
THOSE DECISIONS THAT WOMEN HAVE
TO MAKE. ARE PROBABLY THE ONE
DECISION THEY NEVER WANT TO
HAVE TO MAKE. BUT IT IS ABOT
THE HEALTH OF THE MOTHER. AND
THE FACTTHAT THERE IS
SOMETHING INSIDE OF THAT MOTHER
TO BE OR MOTHER WHO WANTED TO
BE. THAT IS NOT TO GROWING.
THAT SCIENCE. AND UNFORTUNATELY
IT IS LIFE. SO I WOULD JUST
URGE US. TO NOT CONTINUE TO
SUGGEST THAT WOMEN ARE SECONDS.
AND THAT THE RIGHT FOR US TO
DETERMINE HOW OUR BODIES ARE
TREATED IN WHO HAS CONTROL OVER
THEM. IT'S NOT SECONDS. AND
THAT WE SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS
AND CLINICS VETERAN COMMUNITY
IS QUITE FRANKLY THAT NO ONE
REALLY CARES ABOUT UNTIL IT'S
EXCITING. TO ALLOW THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS AND COMMUNITY
CLINICS TO PROVIDE CARE THAT
OFTEN TIMES NO ONE ELSE IS
PROVIDING. SO I ASK. WE SUPPORT
SELF DETERMINATION AND BODILY
AUTONOMY AND A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE AND THINK AND MAKE
DECISIONS FOR HERSELF BY
SUPPORTING SR SIX THANK YOU.
SENATOR WEST OF. THANK YOU
AMONG A MOMENT EVEN THOSE
NUMBERS IT DOESN'T HAVE MY OWN
LIKE SO. I'D LOVE TO SHARE THE-
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
MAKE A FEW COMMENTS HERE AND I
JUST WANT TO SHARE MY OWN
PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE ON THIS
MATTER AS A- AS A LATINO
CATHOLIC. WHO HAS OFTEN BEEN
ASKED HOW DO I RECONCILE HAS A
CATHOLIC MY POSITIONS ON. ON
ALLOWING A WOMAN'S CHOICE. AND
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT IS OFTEN
RAISED BEEN SOMEBODY
PERSONALLY. THAT SUPPORTS LIFE
SUPPORTS- IT I'M NOT I'M
PERSONALLY OPPOSED TO ABORTION
TRULY. AND THAT'S AN AREA WHERE
I OFTEN STRUGGLE. BUT I LOOK AT
THIS FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
WHAT IT REALLY IS I OFTEN I
I'VE BEEN HERE FOR YEARS
HEARING ARGUMENTS HOW BLESSED
GOVERNMENT IS MORE. AND- FROM
FROM ONE SIDE OF THE AISLE
OFTEN SAYS LESS GOVERNMENT IN
YOUR LIFE IS BETTER WE WANT
FREEDOM. AND THEN WHEN I HEAR
HOW THEY ARGUE FOR MORE
GOVERNMENT. IN DETERMINING
INDIVIDUAL FAMILY PLANNING I
CAN'T RENTS ARE RECONCILED THAT
THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE TO
ME. AND WITH THIS REALLY
TRANSLATES TO. IS IT WILL YOU
KNOW WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
IMPOSING LAWS ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THAT'S CALLED AN
UNFUNDED MANDATE. THIS IS THIS
IS AN UNFUNDED MANDATE ON ON
WOMEN'S LIVES. A GOVERNMENT
DECIDES YOU HAVE TO HAVE.
CHILDREN BUT DOES NOTHING. TO
SUPPORT THE UPBRINGING OF THOSE
CHIP CHILDREN. BACKED UP BY AN
IDEOLOGY OF PEOPLE THAT SAY. WE
SUPPORT LIFE BEFORE IT'S BORN
BUT WON IT ONCE IT'S BORN. WE
DON'T SUPPORT IT ANYMORE. LET
THOSE CHILDREN LIVE IN POVERTY.
LET THEM LIVE IN INEQUALITY
WITHOUT EQUAL ACCESS TO
DRINKABLE WATER WITHOUT EQUAL
ACCESS TO QUALITY EDUCATION.
AND I'VE BEEN HEARING HERE NOT
ELEVEN YEARS. DEBATING
PROVIDING. EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE PEOPLE OF OUR STATE.
AND JUST TRYING DOT TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW SOMEBODY ON THE-
ONE HAND COULD SUPPORT. LIFE
BEFORE IT'S BORN BUT ONCE IT'S
BORN. NOT SUPPORTED AT WHEN.
IT'S MOST APPROPRIATE THIS IF
YOU REALLY LOOK AT WHAT THIS IS.
THIS IS GOVERNMENT CONTROL OF
FAMILY PLANNING THE GOVERNMENT
SAYING YOU MUST HAVE A CHILD
AND WE WILL HAVE NOTHING TO DO.
HOW THAT CHILD IS RAISED
WHETHER IT'S PROVIDED WITH A
LITTLE HOME HEALTH CARE
EDUCATION. THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
AT BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE THAT
CHILD BUT I WANT TO SEND YOU
WITH ONE THOUGHT TODAY AS- WELL
AFTER THIS VOTE WE COULD
PROBABLY GUESS HOW THE SPORT'S
GONNA. TURN OUT. WELL I WOULD
LIKE TO SEND EVERYONE WITH A
FIVE. IS THAT A FORM OF SLAVERY.
GOVERNMENT SAYING TO WOMEN YOU
MUST DO THIS YOU MUST DO THAT.
WITHOUT YOUR CHOICE SOMETHING
THAT SIGNIFICANT IS GIVING
BIRTH AND RAISING A CHILD THE
GOVERNMENT SAYING YOU MUST DO
THAT. IS THAT ANOTHER FORM OF
SLAVERY IN ARE WE DEBATING.
ANOTHER FORM OF SLAVERY HERE IN
THE SENATE FLOOR. PLEASE
SUPPORT S. R. SIX. SENATOR PAN.
I THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT-
SENATORS- I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
S. R. SIX AS A POSITION- WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND MARKS
THE FORTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
SUPREME COURT DECISION ROE
VERSUS WADE A GOOD FOR SO I
JUST POINT OUT SINCE I'M
GENERALLY A DIVIDEND SPACE TO A
POLICY MAKER THAT ACTUALLY-
HERE IN CALIFORNIA- OUR
POLICIES- FOR THOSE WHO SAY
THEY WANT TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF ABORTIONS ACTUALLY HAS BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL. SHE REDUCE THE
PORTIONS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BY OVER 60% SINCE
THE EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES. SO
I HAVE YOU KNOW WHEN PEOPLE
ACTUALLY WANT TO TALK ABOUT
SOME WE REALLY ABOUT REDUCING
ABORTIONS YOU SHOULD BE
DEFINITELY FULLY IN SUPPORT OF-
ACCESS TO CONTRACEPTION- MANY
OTHER POLICIES WELL THAT WE
HAVE PURSUED HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF ABORTIONS. HOWEVER I
ALSO POINT OUT AND I KNOW THAT-
THAT OTHER SEPARATE POINT ON
THE FLOOR THAT IS A POSITION I
THINK THAT. MIGHT COME TO
HEALTH CARE- THAT SHOULD REALLY
BE A DECISION BETWEEN THE-
PATIENT AND THE DOCTOR
INDIVIDUAL THE DOCTOR. ABOUT
THEIR OWN HEALTH AND- YOU KNOW
PEOPLE HAVE DIFFERENT BELIEFS.
THEY AND THE IT'S TAKEN STATION
SINCERELY FOLLOW THEIR OWN
BELIEFS BUT THEN THE QUESTION
IS DO WE AS GOVERNMENT IMPOSE-
THESE RULES TO RESTRICT
PEOPLE'S PERSONAL CHOICES
ESPECIALLY THOSE CHOICES DON'T
AFFECT. THE HEALTH OF THE
PEOPLE AROUND THEM. AND- SO. I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT- WE SHOULD NOT
BE INTERFERING IN THIS WAY IN
THE PRIVATE PERSONAL DECISIONS
OF WOMEN. THAT EVERY PERSON HAS
THE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO MAKE
THEIR OWN REPRODUCTIVE
DECISIONS THAT INCLUDES ACCESS
TO REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH NOW
INCLUDES ABORTIONS WHICH IS
HEALTHCARE. AND SO CERTAINLY I
THINK THAT FOR THOSE WHO WANT
TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
ABORTIONS WE SHOULD CONTINUE
SUPPORT POLICIES THAT WE
PURSUED HERE TO SEE THE
CALIFORNIA WHICH HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN DOING SO. AND
CERTAINLY WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT OUR CONSTITUTION.
CONTINUES TO PROTECT THE
PRIVACY. OF THE PEOPLE OF THE
WHOLE COUNTRY THE EXPOSITION OF
ROE VERSUS WADE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT PRESS ARE
SIX THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN CENTER SKINNER YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THESE TOPICS I
SUPPOSE SOME OF US MAY AT TIMES
WANT TO SKIRT BRINGING FORWARD
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES- AND
HAVING DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE
VERY PERSONAL VERY SENSITIVE
AND FOR MANY VERY EMOTIONAL.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
SOMETIMES HAVE THESE DEBATES
BECAUSE. WHAT I WOULD ASSERT IS
THAT WE CAN NO WAY. FOR TO
UNDERSTAND. WHY WHAT GOES
THROUGH ONE'S MIND WHAT ARE THE
FACTORS THAT INFLUENCED HER
DECISION. WHEN SHE CHOOSES
EITHER TO PROCEED WITH THE
PREGNANCY OR TO ABORT. AND THAT
IS REALLY WITH THE BRILLIANCE
AND IMPORTANCE OF THE COURT'S
RULING IS IN ROE VERSUS WADE.
IS THAT IT GAVE WOMEN. AGENCY
OVER THEIR BODIES AGENCY OVER
THEIR REPRODUCTIVE CHOICES IT
DOES NOT IMPOSE ABORTION. IT
DOES NOT IMPOSE THAT SOMEONE
PROCEED WITH THE PREGNANCY
RATHER IT GIVES THE WOMAN THE
WOMAN THE ABILITY TO DECIDE.
NOW IT IS INTERESTING. THE
EVOLUTION OF THE POLITICAL
VIEWPOINTS ON THIS ISSUE. IN
FACT IT IS THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
THROUGHOUT THE SIXTIES AND PART
IN GOOD PART OF THE SEVENTIES.
WHO WAS OVERALL FAR STRONGER
PRO CHOICE THAN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY. THAT OBVIOUSLY HAS
REVERSED ITSELF SOME OVERTIME.
BUT THE ISSUE FOR ME IT'S NOT
AN IDEOLOGICAL ISSUE. MY STRONG
BELIEF IN A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
HAVE AGENCY OVER HER BODY AND
HER REPRODUCTIVE CHOICES HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH ALL IDEOLOGY
IT'S ABOUT PERSONAL EXERCISE IN
THE SAME WAY. THAT WE DO NOT AS
A GOVERNMENT IMPOSED
INTERFERENCE ON THE EXERCISE OF
PERSONAL CHOICE REGARDING ONE'S
RELIGIOUS VIEWS. OR EVEN ONES
POLITICAL VIEWS. THE
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR WHICH A
PERSON MAY A WOMAN MAY CHOOSE
TO HAVE AN ABORTION MAYBE THAT
THEIR HEALTH IS IMPACTED IT MAY
BE THE CIRCUMSTANCES FOR WHICH
THEY GOT PREGNANT. OR MAYBE ANY
OTHER NUMBER OF THINGS. BUT
THAT IS THE WOMAN'S RIGHT. AND
THAT WAS THE PURPOSE OF THE
RULING AND WHY IT CITED THE
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT WHICH WAS
THE PRIVACY AMENDMENT. AND IT
IS SOMETHING THAT AMERICANS AS
I CITED EARLIER STILL STRONGLY
BELIEVE AND HOLD. AND WITH THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON S.
R. SIX. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES NO
BACKER. HI GORGEOUS NO BRADFORD
HI CABALLERO FIVE CORTESE HI
DALLY NO DODD. HI DERISIVE. HI
EGGMAN HI GLAZER. GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
HI JONES. NO KAMLAGER I LAYERED
I LEYVA I MCGUIRE. HI MELINDA'S
NO MAN HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. A
TOTAL OF BOTH. NO HAN AYE
PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER HI AMBERG HI WHITE
HOUSE SKI HI WIENER AYE WILK.
NOW IS TWENTY NINE KNOWS EIGHT.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTY CENTER GONZALEZ. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ RELATIVE TO
CAMBODIAN GENOCIDE MEMORIAL
WEEK. MATTER SENATOR GONZALEZ
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTION TWENTY SIX WHICH
WOULD DESIGNATE THE WEEK OF
APRIL ELEVENTH THROUGH APRIL
SEVENTEENTH THAT'S CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WEEK WHICH IS
ALSO THE SAME WEEK AS A
CAMBODIAN NEW YEAR. THIS IS A
TIME OF BOTH REMEMBRANCE AND
RENEWAL HAPPINESS AND OF COURSE
UNDERSTANDING AND RESPECTING
THE PAST IN SADNESS. ON APRIL
SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE THE COMMUNIST FORCES OF
THE COME AYE ROUGE LED BY THE
POPE POSTS. THESE POWER IN
CAMBODIA AND BEGAN A REIGN OF
TERROR THAT TARGETED ACADEMICS
PROFESSIONALS INTELLECTUALS
RELIGIOUS LEADERS AND ETHNIC
MINORITIES AND SOUGHT TO
DESTROY INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS
BUDDHIST TEMPLES SCHOOLS
LIBRARIES DANCE AND MUSIC. IN
LESS THAN FOUR YEARS OF RULE
THE COME AYE ROUGE MURDERED
NEARLY TWO MILLION CAMBODIANS
ROUGHLY 20% OF THE POPULATION
THROUGH FORCED LABOR PRISON
CAMPS. AND EXECUTION IN WHAT
BECAME KNOWN AS THE KILLING
FIELDS. AFTER THE OVERTHROW OF
THE COMITE ROUGE CLOSE TO ONE
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
CAMBODIANS IMMIGRATED TO THE
UNITED STATES AS ROUGH AS
REFUGEES. AND IT BECOME AN
INTEGRAL PART OF THE FABRIC OF
OUR STATE. CALIFORNIA IS NOW
HOME TO A LARGE CAMBODIAN
POPULATION IN THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH. IN THE SET SENATE
DISTRICT THIRTY THREE IN WHICH
I AM PROUDLY REPRESENTING IS.
HOME TO THE LARGEST CAMBODIAN
COMMUNITY OUTSIDE OF SOUTHEAST
ASIA. RECOGNIZING CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE MEMORIAL WEEK WILL
HONOR THEIR SURVIVORS AND THEIR
DESCENDANTS FOR THEIR COURAGE
IN THE FACE OF TERROR WILL ALSO
HONOR HONORING THE SURVIVORS.%
FOR THE CONTINUED CONTRIBUTIONS
TO OUR STATE AND COUNTRY AS
LEADERS AND ONE OF THE MOST
DIVERSE STATES IN THE NATION
IT'S IMPORTAT FOR US TO
SOLEMNLY REMEMBER THESE PAST
EVENTS TO ENSURE THAT THEY
NEVER ARE REPEATED AGAIN IN THE
FUTURE. AND REMEMBRANCE LAST
WEEK I SHARED THE GIFT OF A
CROSSBAR FOR EACH SENATOR THE
CRIME A SCARF IS A SYMBOL FOR
THE CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY THAT
REPRESENTS COURAGE DIGNITY AND
PERSEVERANCE. IT IS ONE BY
WOMEN MEN AND CHILDREN AND IT'S
WROTE RELEVANCE IN EVERYDAY
LIFE GIVE GIVES ITS IMPORTANCE.
SYMBOLIC VALUE I HOPE YOU CAN
TAKE IT HOME AND SHARE WITH THE
REST OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS AS WE
CELEBRATE CAMBODIAN NEW YEAR AS
WELL. LASTLY I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE CONSTITUENTS FOR THEIR
SUPPORT AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT YOU JOIN ME IN THIS SMALL
ACT OF REMEMBRANCE OF THE
NEARLY TWO MILLION CAMBODIANS.
THAT WERE LOTS OF THE GENOCIDE
BY VOTING I AND SENATE
RESOLUTION. TWENTY SIX THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. SENATOR
PER. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS SAYS CHAIR OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER CAUCUS-
MORE RISE IN SUPPORT OF SR
TWENTY SIX SO I THINK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM LONG BEACH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD HI THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT PART OF
WORLD HISTORY- BUT IT'S ALSO
CERTAINLY HAD AN IMPACT ON THE
UNITED STATES AS MANY OF THE
CAMBODIANS AGAIN AFTER- THE
OVERTHROW OF. THE- EACH MACHINE
THEN BECAME REFUGEES AND I
THINK AS WE THINK ABOUT. OUR
POLICIES AROUND REFUGEES WE
NEED TO REMEMBER THINK ABOUT
THE HISTORY. OF DAY CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE AND OTHER GENOCIDES
AND- OUR ROLE IN THE WORLD AS
AS THE AMERICANS. IN HELPING-
PEOPLES WHO HAVE SUFFERED ON
AND- IN THE SITUATIONS. SO THIS
IS A VERY IMPORTANT PART OF
THAT REMEMBRANCE IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF THE HISTORY.
OF NOT ONLY THE WORLD BUT ALSO
OUR COUNTRY AND CERTAINLY HERE
IN CALIFORNIA IS- WE- HAVE
WELCOMED AND- NEED TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE A- HOME FOR-
CAMBODIAN SORT OF NOW WILL CALL
CALIFORNIA HOME AND NOW.
CALIFORNIANS CALIFORNIANS AND-
THAT- AND TO REMEMBER THEIR
HISTORY- I OF SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SENATOR BURGESS. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF OUR SENATOR FROM.
LONG BEACH IS. RESOLUTION TODAY
WHEN I WAS- IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL THERE WAS A BIG INFLUX
OF CAMBODIAN CHILDREN. AND IT
WAS KIND OF UNUSUAL WE HAD A
RELATIVELY HOMOGENOUS
COMMUNITY- AT THAT PARTICULAR
TIME AND WE HAD PROBABLY I
WOULD SAY TEN TO TWENTY FIVE
CAMBODIAN CHILDREN THAT WERE
BROUGHT IN TO- TO THE AREA THEN
OF COURSE WENT TO SCHOOL WITH.
IT TOOK A GOOD LONG WHILE FOR
US TO APPROACH THEM AND FOR
THEM TO FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH
WITH US. I REMEMBER- COMING
HOME ONE DAY AND TRYING TO ASK
EXACTLY WHERE CAMBODIA WAS I
WAS ELEMENTARY SCHOOL MY FATHER.
I TRY TO GIVE ME A LITTLE BIT
OF HISTORY ON THE CORROSION
FULL PART IN IN WHAT THE
GENOCIDE. WAS ALL ABOUT IT OF
COURSE HE HARKENED IT AS A GOOD
FATHER ALWAYS WOULD INTO
UNDERSTANDABLE TERMS. BY
REFERRING IT TO THE GREEK
GENOCIDE OF MINOR ASIA. BUT THE
CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA I HAPPEN TO HAVE A
VERY SIZEABLE. SOUTHEAST ASIAN
COMMUNITY IN THE FRESNO AREA IN
THE EXTENDED VALLEY- SPECIALLY-
WITHIN THE LONG COMMUNITY AND
MANY OF YOU MAY KNOW THAT THE
LONG SOUGHT FOUGHT ALONGSIDE US
DURING VIETNAM THEY WERE ALSO
RELOCATED TO CALIFORNIA MOSTLY
IN THE VALLEY. SEE YOU AS ONE
OF FAKE THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD IT ACTUALLY
DESERVESREMEMBRANCE- I THINK
ONE OF OUR OTHER COLLEAGUES
EARLIER TALKED ABOUT THE
TRIBUNAL WORK THAT HE- WORKED
ON I THINK IT'S WITH RWANDA-
THE COMMUTER ROUGE TRIBUNAL IS
A VERY INTERESTING- BODY
ESTABLISHED IN INTERNATIONAL
LAW. I THINK WE LEARNED A LOT.
ON HOW TO HOLD- INDIVIDUALS
RESPONSIBLE IN THE COMPLEXITY
AND DIFFICULTY. OF HOW YOU
OVERCOME AND RECONCILE
COMMUNITY ONCE IT'S EXPERIENCE
SOMETHING LIKE A TWO MILLION
DOLLAR TWO MILLION PERSON. ALL
IN LIVES LOST EVENTS SO ONCE
AGAIN. H. APPRECIATE BRING THIS
FORWARD. SENATOR UMBERG- THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS-
THANK YOU FOR CALLING FROM LONG
BEACH FROM BRINGING THIS
FORWARD SUPPORT FOR US TO
REMEMBER FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS THE GENOCIDE THAT
OCCURRED IN CAMBODIA WE HAD
HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE DAY JUST
JUST RECENTLY CORD PRESS
REMEMBER THE THAT THE LESSONS
LEARNED THE HOLOCAUST
REMEMBERED THAT GENOCIDE
CONTINUES EVEN TO THIS DAY IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT FOR US TO
REMEMBER THE ECONOMIC AND
CULTURAL CONTRIBUTIONS THE
CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY THE
SUFFERING THAT PROCESS ALTHOUGH
WAS FORTY SIX YEARS AGO THERE
ARE MANY MANY MANY. AMONG US
WHO ARE STILL SUFFERING FROM
THE ATROCITIES SO IT'S
IMPORTANT WE ONE COMMEMORATE
THE CAMBODIAN PEOPLE AND TO
RECOGNIZE THEIR SUFFERING AND
ANGUISH AND THEIR CONTRIBUTION
TO OUR COMMUNITY THANK YOU. IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING NINE SENATOR
GONZALEZ YOU MAY CONCLUDE WHEN
I THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR ALL
OF THEIR- COMMENTS AND OF CAN
THIS IS A TIME OF REMEMBRANCE
AND RENEWAL FOR CAMBODIAN
COMMUNITY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHEN I THINK IN RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR BIBLE. THIS ITEM
IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
CONSENT. SAYING NO OBJECTION
FIVE THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO I AM
SORRY THIRTY SEVEN. NO ZERO.
THE- THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MEMBERS WORRY WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. WE HAVE. TO
COMMITTEES THAT. SENATOR WESSEL.
AND. SENATOR WEST OF YES
FOLLOWING THE ADJOURNMENT OF
THE SENATE- THE ENERGY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS UTILITIES
COMMITTEE WILL MEET HERE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR UPON THE GERMAN.
VERY GOOD- CENTER CORTESE. SO.
HELLO REPUBLICAN APPOINTMENT TO
A COMMITTEE WILL CONVENE UPON
GERMAN OF THE FOR SESSION AND
FOR TWO OR THREE THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS IS THE TIME TO
ADDRESS THE JOURNEY IN MEMORY.
SENATOR NUMBER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TO COMMEMORATE
AND REMARKED UPON THE AMAZING
LIFE OF BILLION TRAN IN HIS
PASSING IS A CONSTITUENT IN THE
BELOVED COMMUNITY MEMBER FROM
FOUNTAIN VALLEY. IAN TRêN WAS
BORN IN SAIGON VIETNAM ON
NOVEMBER FOURTH NINETEEN THIRTY
TWO HE SERVED HIS COUNTRY AS A
MEMBER OF THE NATIONAL POLICE
FORCE. PUBLIC OF VIETNAM AND
LIKE MANY OTHERS BECAME A
POLITICAL REFUGEE AFTER THE
FALL OF SAIGON. DERIVED UNITED
STATES WITH HIS WIFE AND THREE
OF HIS SEVEN CHILDREN IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT. BUT WITH
DETERMINATION AND HOPE FOR A
BETTER LIFE. PRESENTER FAMILY
WORKED LONG HOURS DEMANDING
MANUAL LABOR JOBS INCLUDING
WORK AT A GARMENT FACTORY IN
LETTERS SECURITY COMPANIES
SUPPORTERS FAMILY AND BRING HIS
ENTIRE FAMILY HERE. LATER IN
LIFE IS TRêN OKAY BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY IN ORANGE COUNTY BY
VOLUNTEERING FOR VOTER
REGISTRATION DRIVES WORKING
ELECTION POLLING CENTERS. IT
WAS A FAMILIAR FACE AT HIS
LOCAL SENIOR COMMUNITY CENTER.
MISTER TRAN WAS A KIND AND
GENEROUS SOUL SACRIFICING
EVERYTHING FOR THE WELFARE OF
HIS FAMILY IN AT THE END OF HIS
JOURNEY HE GAVE SAVINGS WITH
THOSE CHILDREN HIS
GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. AMBER DEARLY BY
HIS WIFE LAUNCH HIS SEVEN
CHILDREN LONG. DAVID DAVID THE
LATE HUSBAND OF MINE- STAFFER
QUINN TRANH. TUY WINE. THON
WINE MEN. TEN ORANG ANTON IT IS
GREAT IS TEN GRANDCHILDREN ON
CON. DIçN LYNN JULIE. ALEXIS
CHECK ME TRAVIS AND CINDY AND
TWO GREAT GRANDCHILDREN
ALEXANDER AND BENJAMIN
COLLEAGUES AYE. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING IN ADJOURNING IN MEMORY
OF BILLION TRANS. PLEASE BRING
HIS NAME TO THE DESK SO HE CAN
BE APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED
BY THE SENATE. SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY TO ENSURE IN MEMORY
OF MARIO'S CUEVAS AMORA A
CONSUL OF MEXICO IN ITS SANTA
ANA CONSULATE WHO PASSED AWAY
ON MARCH THIRD TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AFTER A LONG AND VALIANT
BATTLE WITH CANCER MARIO CUEVAS
MOORE WAS BORN APRIL FOURTH
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR IN MEXICO
CITY HE DEVTED HIS LIFE TO
PUBLIC SERVICE HIS FAMILY AND
HIS COUNTRY. CONSUL CUEVAS A
MORE INTUITIVE THIRTY YEAR
DISTINGUISHED PROFESSIONAL
CAREER IN THE FOREIGN SERVICE
LOVED SO DEEPLY HE RECEIVED HIS
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS FROM
THE NATIONAL AUTONOMOUS
UNIVERSITY OF MEXICO AND THEN
WENT ON TO EARN A MASTER'S
DEGREE IN DIPLOMATIC STUDIES
FROM MEXICO'S DIPLOMATIC
ACADEMY OF THE MINISTRY OF
FOREIGN AFFAIRS CONSUL CUEVAS
MOORE BEGAN HIS DIPLOMATIC
CAREER AT THE MINISTRY OF
FOREIGN AFFAIRS IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE WHERE HE SERVED AS
CHIEF OF STAFF TO THE OFFICE OF
THE FOREIGN MINISTER. HE'S
DEFINITELY EL ROLES ARE
PROGRESSIVELY GREATER
RESPONSIBILITY IN MEXICO'S
FOREIGN SERVICE AS YOU SERVICE
TOOK HIM AROUND THE WORLD HIS
POST INCLUDED WORK AT THE
MEXICO MISSION TO THE UNITED
NATIONS IN GENEVA THE CONSUL
GENERAL OF MEXICO IN MONTREAL
IN MEXICO'S CONSULATES IN SAN
DIEGO AND NEW YORK AND FINALLY
IN CALIFORNIA IN JUNE OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN HE TOOK OFFICE AS THE
CONSUL FROM MEXICO MEXICO'S
CONSULATE IN SANTA ANA. YES
IT'S LEADER CUEVAS MOORE SAW
HIS MISSION AS HELPING TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF MEXICAN
NATIONALS IN THOSE OF MEXICAN
DESCENT GROUPS THAT COMBINE TO
MAKE UP NEARLY A THIRD OF
ORANGE COUNTY POPULATION
ACCORDING TO U. S. CENSUS DATA
IN THE MOST RECENT- SHE
COMMUNICATED COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY INDICATORS REPORT
THERE ARE PRICE ME NINE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE
OF MEXICAN DESCENT IN ORANGE
COUNTY INCLUDING JUST OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
WHO WERE BORN IN MEXICO. IN A
TWENTY FIFTEEN INTERVIEW WITH
THE ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER
SHORTLY AFTER ASSUMING HIS POST
IN SANTA ANA CONSEQUENCES TO
MORE SAID HIS GOALS WERE TO
EMPOWER MEXICANS AND MEXICAN
AMERICANS TO RECEIVE MORE
SERVICES FOR WHICH THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE TO BETTER ACCESS
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
TO FORCEFULLY EXERCISE. THEIR
RIGHTS AS PART OF THAT WORK
CONSECRATE ASSUME. SAID THE
IMPRINTED DORIS. WHICH WOMEN
VICTIM OF TO VIOLENCE IN
ESTABLISHING THEIR OWN
BUSINESSES. AS WELL AS A LEGAL
DEFENSE PROGRAM FOR MEXICAN
RESIDENTS IN THE UNITED STATES.
CONSECRATORS MORE WAS
INACCESSIBLE PROACTIVE AND
COMPASSIONATE PUBLIC SERVANT.
WHO LED BY EXAMPLE IN HIS WORK
TO EMPOWER PEOPLE TO BETTER
HELP MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY.
AND HELP THEMSELVES AND EACH
OTHER. CONSUL MARIO CUEVAS
MOORE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
ERA SALLY TRAY HO. AND THEIR
DAUGHTERS THE LYDIA AND POLAND.
AND HIS SON IN LAW EL DORADO.
HIS PASSING LEAVES A DEEP VOID
IN THEIR LIVES AND IN OUR
COMMUNITY AS WELL AND I ASKED
WE ADJOURNED TODAY IN HIS
MEMORY. PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
TO THE DESK SO HE CAN BE PER.
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED.
SENATOR BAKER AND THEN SENATOR
LARRY. GOOD AFTERNOON MINUTE
PRESENT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
OPPORTUNITY TO HONOR. BELONGS
IN EARLIER THIS HONEST AND
DECENT LEGISLATURES ARE AT
LEGISLATORS EVER WAS JEANNE MOE
AND THE PASSED AWAY LAST WEEK
AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY FOUR. HE
REPRESENTED NORTHERN CEMETERY
COUNTY. THE VERY SAME SEAT NOW
HELD BY SUN AND OUR COLLEAGUE
AND FRIEND KEVIN MULLIN. GM
BODY THE BEST ABOUT PUBLIC
SERVICE INTRUDE BELIEVED IN THE
POWER OF GOVERNMENT TO IMPROVE
THE LIVES OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN WAS BORN
NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN A THIRD
GENERATION CALIFORNIA. HIS HIGH
SCHOOL'S SEE HISTORY AND CIVICS
TEACHER IN SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO.
ASSEMBLY TENANT SIMULTANEOUSLY
BE A DEVOTED AND LOVING FATHER
AND HUSBAND ALL THE WHILE
SERVING ON THE SOUTH SAN
FRANCISCO CITY COUNCIL. DURING
THIS TIME HE INSPIRED SO MANY
SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO HIGH
SCHOOLERS IN THE PUBLIC SERVICE
MANY ELECTED EMPLOYEES AND
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES AT THAT I'VE
RUN INTO TODAY THANK YOU MORE
ONE FOR OPENING THE DOOR TO
THEM. IN THE CURRENT VICE MAYOR
MARKING GAULLISTS OURSELVES
YOUR CISCO. WHO TOLD ME QUOTE
JEAN IS THE REASON WHY I'M AND
PUBLIC SERVICE. HE WAS ELECTED
TO THE STATE SEN ASSEMBLY IN
TWO THOUSAND TWO FOR THREE
TERMS. EAVING IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. DURING THAT TIME IT'S A
GREAT PLOT PRIDE IN SHARING THE
ASSEMBLY. COMMITTEE AND THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE. HE
BREAKS RETIREMENT ACTIVELY
AFTER LEAVING LEGISLATURE IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. SPENDING
TIME WITH HIS FIVE GRANDSONS
SERVING ON NONPROFIT BOARDS
FISHING PROVIDING COUNSEL TO
THOSE STARTING THEIR POLITICAL
CAREERS AND FOLLOWING HIS
BELOVED SAN FRANCISCO GIANTS.
SHE LEFT A TREMENDOUS LEGACY WE
SEND SO MUCH LOVE. TO KEVIN AND
THE MORE FAMILY DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME. WE ARE BETTER
COMMUNITY FOR HAVING HAD JEAN
AND AT. CENTER LAYERED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT.
I ALSO RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF JIM MOLAN I SERVE THE
SAME SIX YEARS IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY AS JANE DID IN THE
SAME CLASS. HE WAS KNOWN AS WAS
NOTED IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
CHRONICLE MEMORIAL AS THE CAL
RIPKEN OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY
BECAUSE HE NEVER MISSED A
SINGLE VOTE ON THE FLOOR OR THE
COMMITTEE DURING HIS SIX YEARS.
IN WHAT WAS. USUALLY A VERY
RAMBUNCTIOUS HOUSE. HE WAS THE
ADULTS YOU COULD TELL THAT HE
HAD BEEN A COACH AT A HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER FOR OVER THREE
DECADES BY THE WAY HE
NAVIGATED. OF THAT SYSTEM. IT A
VERY DRY SENSE OF HUMOR. WE
WERE ONCE BOTH CALLED TO THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE AS FIRST
TIMERS AND I REMEMBER HE SAID
TO ME. THIS IS LIKE BEING
CALLED TO THE DEAN OF BOYS
OFFICE. WHEN WE WENT TO TURNED
OUT TO- THE OTHER SIDE WAS
GOING TO PRESENT A BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND HE WANTED THE TWO
OF US TO GO IN AND LISTEN AND
THEN GO OUTSIDE AND RESPOND ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSE. WE DID
THAT AND I THOUGHT I GAVE A
GREAT ARTICULATE ANALYSIS OF
THE BUDGET AND THEN JEANS COM
WE JUST LOOKED AT THE SCRUM OF
REPORTERS AND SAID THE GOOD
THING SO MANY PRISONERS ARE
BEING LET OUT EARLY BECAUSE ALL
BE OUT ON THE SIDEWALKS WITH
THE KINDERGARTENERS. AND IT WAS
ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS WE
COULDN'T HELP YOURSELF JUST
LAUGHED OUT LOUD. I DID IN THE
MEMORIES FOR A LOCAL TEACHER
WHO WAS A LONGTIME CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER. AND HE WALKED OVER AND
SAID- I KNEW ROOF AND JUST WENT
THROUGH A FRIENDSHIP. HE WAS
JUST CLEARLY SOMEBODY THAT.
KNEW HIS COLLEAGUES AND WAS
BELOVED. AND THEN THERE WAS
THIS TIME WHEN WE EACH HAD
DIFFICULT SITUATIONS IN OUR OWN
DISTRICT. I HAD A HORRIBLE BILL
THAT FLEW OUT OF THE STATE
SENATE SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN ANYMORE- I KNOW. THAT
WOULD HAVE REMOVED ALL THE
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS ON ON
BOARD AND REPLACE THEM WITH A
WHOLE NEW GROUP OF PEOPLE. JEAN
REVERSED HIMSELF WAS THE SWING
VOTE IN KILLING THAT BILL. AND
THEN LO AND BEHOLD HE HAD A
CITY IN HIS DISTRICT THAT ARE
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
JUDGMENT AGAINST IT ON A LAND
USE MEASURE IT WAS A CITY THAT
WAS VERY SMALL. AND HE HAD A
BILL THAT WOULD HAVE FIXED IT
THAT THE ENVIRONMENTALISTS JUST
HATE I DIDN'T LIKE THE BILL BUT
I WENT TO HIM AND I SAID JEAN
IF YOU GET TO FORTY VOTES IT'S
LIKE YOU GOTTA COME TO ME ARE
WILL HELP YOU IN THIS AT ALL I
REALLY DON'T WANT TO MAKE YOU
DO THAT. AND HE JUST HE
CONSIDERED EVERYBODY'S IN A
GOOD WAY. HE REALLY WAS A
FAMILY MAN TO LOVE THIS FAMILY
IS PROUD OF HIS SON KEVIN OVER
IN THE ASSEMBLY AS ANYBODY
COULD BE IN FACT ONE OF. OUR
KEVIN'S TWINS HAS JEAN AS IS A
MIDDLE NAME AND MY HEART JUST
GOES OUT TO THEM TO HIS FAMILY
TO HIS FRIENDS HE WAS A
GENTLEMAN IN THE IN THE BEST
SENSE OF THE WORD AND HE'S ONE
OF THE MOST HONORABLE PEOPLE
THAT I'VE EVER SERVED WITH SO I
TO JOIN IN A JOURNEY IN MEMORY.
OF JEAN MORE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND- PLEASE BRING THE S. FORMER
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS NAME TO THE
DEATHS OF THE HE MAY BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE SENATE. AMBER'S WE'RE GOING
TO RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS I'D
LIKE TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM FORTY
SENATE BILL FOUR OH SEVEN TO
THE INACTIVEFILE THANK YOU
THIRD. IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR ATKINS THE
DESK IT'S CLEAR. SENATE
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH OUR
NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED
FOR THURSDAY THIS THURSDAY
APRIL TWENTY SECOND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AT NINE AM. MEMBERS
IT CENTER THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE WE WILL
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE AM.